mais cette fois-ci c'est effectivement
d'une autre ampleur et puis ça dure
avant c'était juste piqûre de je sais
pas si on peut dire de moustiques mais
enfin voilà qui était infligé en
territoire russe jamais revendiqué par
Kiev là c'est une opération de plus
grande ampleur alors qu'il n'y ait
toujours pas revendiqué par l'Ukraine
officiellement pour une raison bien
simple c'est que l'Ukraine c'est très
bien que si elle revendiquait son
officiellement à en montrer d'un échelon
dans la tension avec Moscou et que ce
serait très mal vu par les alliés
occidentaux de Kiev donc Kiev ne va
jamais reconnaître officiellement son
application mais de toute façon il y a
quand même deux possibilités concernant
cette attaque quand même d'ampleur
encore une fois soit ce sont des
éléments
Ukrainiens des forces spéciales en
quelque sorte qui interviennent le
territoire ukrainien soit ce sont des
éléments russes acquis à la cause de
pièces l'un de ces groupes d'ailleurs a
revendiqué les attaques la Légion
liberté pour la Russie qui combat le
régime de Vladimir Poutine donc des
Russes anti-putine et qui collaborent en
quelque sorte avec les Ukrainiens
toujours est-il qu'évidemment le Kremlin
vous l'avez dit exprime sa préoccupation
parce que c'est le deuxième jour ça
c'est un peu une première et puis pour
l'image de la Russie franchement c'est
pas terrible ça veut dire que les
défenses russes d'une part sont
perméables et que d'autres parts la
frontière la fameuse frontière entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine et bien visiblement
elle montre des signes de forte porosité
j'ajoute que Kremlin appelle à faire
plus d'efforts ce sont ces mots pour
contrer ces incursions armées donc qui
sont toujours en cours magoron barmouth
on vient de le voir grâce au reportage
de nos envoyer spéciaux il y a aussi
volody merzuelinski on a peut-être les
images qu'on va vous montrer président
ukrainien qui s'est rendu à doniesk ces
dernières heures là aussi rencontrer son
armée on sent quand même que les choses
peu à peu sont en train de bouger cette
contre-offensive qu'on annonce depuis
des semaines on est peut-être en train
d'être dans les pré finalement ça va
peut-être un peu commencé dans les
prémices après combien de temps vous
durer les prémices c'est c'est difficile
à dire puisque il y a eu même de la part
des Ukrainiens différents sons de cloche
un coup on nous disait qu'on était tout
près de la contre-offensive
le jour d'après y compris le président
zen qui disait bon on va on va peut-être
attendre un peu parce qu'on a pas toutes
les armes qu'il nous faudrait ce qui est
sûr c'est que l'armée Ukraine s'est mise
en position de passer à la
contre-offensive donc on verra bien
quand ça se produit on est effectivement
je pense quand même qu'on peut le dire
dans les prémices d'ailleurs les Russes
s'y préparent et là ce sont nos
confrères de la BBC qui ont voilà qui
ont sorti cette carte comme mené une
enquête avec des images satellites
notamment qui montrent les endroits plus
précisément ou les rues sont
considérablement renforcés leur ligne de
défense voilà 1 2 3 4 vous voyez alors
premier élément quand même encrimé vous
voyez donc ça veut dire que les Russes
pensent que les Ukrainiens pourrait
intervenir par la mer par la voie
maritime pour essayer de récupérer la
Crimée après on est clairement plus vous
voyez la ville de tokbak pour couper ses
territoires en deux le numéro 3 oui
c'est c'est un auto une autoroute mais
qui est dans la région de Kerson
clairement et puis le point cadre voyez
c'est pour couper là aussi la continuité
de ce territoire russe et évidemment si
possible reprendre ce qu'il reste de
Mario Paul on voit bien la la crainte
des Russes et alors là ces lignes de
défense que nos confrères ont pu
consulter via des images satellites
montre clairement quand même qu'à
certains endroits on est presque sur 30
km de fortifications
ces petits points noirs sur la carte ça
c'est ce que les rues sont renforcés ces
derniers mois voilà pour empêcher
l'avancée des blindés et des fantassins
ukrainiens et du coup parfois je vous
dis ça ça fait 30 km c'est très long
donc parfois une première tranchée à 3
mètres de profondeur ensuite un champ de
mine ensuite des bunkers ensuite une
deuxième tranchée vraiment ils sont en
train de bulgariser ces territoires ça
veut dire quand même que pour le moment
eux ne se sentent pas d'aller à
l'offensive merci